okay
oh
[Music]
what a lead and what a guest I have to
start what let season four he's a man
I've been hoping to get on this podcast
from pretty much the very start as is
one of the most incredible stories in
sport he was an absolute beast on the
field during his time playing for
Southland Auckland the Hurricanes where
he run the title and of course Worcester
Warriors but on the 4th of January 2020
his life drastically changed as he
suffered a neck injury where he was told
he may never walk again
but they obviously didn't know what kind
of warrior they were talking to as they
proved the medic's wrong very very quick
and on top of all that he is one of the
most genuine Down to Earth layers you
will ever meet he is literally one of
the greats it is Michael fatihilofa
welcome mate thanks for having me Jimmy
sorry for leaving you on scene for about
a year
got her answer happy to be here thanks
bro mate you are saving up for that mic
obviously because that is the best
quality sound I've ever heard on the
other end of a podcast I see I got you
bro what a loud fan from Weaver okay one
uh but mate can't wait to um talk to you
and sort of catch up about how the last
couple years have been from you and hear
it all from your side of the fence no
but how you been bro like you're looking
good looking strong yeah no not too bad
been living here in uh the Cook Islands
for a year and a half now so yeah I'm
enjoying it nice and slow lifestyle
been you know
learning the island ways husking
coconuts and all that
yeah I was kidding when I first moved
over I was getting exposed just
growing up in Auckland City and I didn't
know anything so yeah it was just I
don't know my neighbors watching me
trying to hust coconuts laughing
it's a slide yeah I couldn't do anything
hey yeah because they all burn fires and
stuff so you've got to burn everything
over here just it's taking a while to
learn all these Island ways but
yeah a bit of a local now so
got it unlocked and where are you living
is that your house you're in at the
moment yeah so my my wife is is she's
cooked Island so
her family's got a family house over
here and we're just we're living in it
and kind of looking off the land so uh
worked out pretty well all right how
good and what what's sort of like an
everyday what's everyday life look like
for you at the moment over there
uh just up with the roosters there's
no that's what it is over here yeah yeah
but they just go all day but yeah up
with the roosters you know
coffee and bricky then I usually go do
some rehab yeah at the gym the local gym
just get the body moving because every
morning just feel terribly just yeah
so I just have to get my body moving and
then
yeah jump in the ocean
that's all good so yeah that's that
helps a lot just swimming every day
and then yeah just a man of leisure
after that just whatever wherever it
takes me I'll do it nice and then finish
the night with some Carver
yeah that's a that's a Friday night too
just me and a few other got invited to a
few of the local Carver sessions and now
it's good to get to know some of the
boys on the island yeah no how good so
where are you at physically you
mentioned how hard it is for you to sort
of wake up and get the body moving but
you're obviously walking around now I've
seen you dead lifting more than I can so
um you're pretty you're getting the
arrow
yeah it's a spinal cord injury so I'm
still
considered uh what they call an
incomplete quadriplegic so okay
I still have impairment of all all four
limbs
but yeah just I don't know they thought
I was going to be in a wheelchair and
all that but
somehow managed to walk and
yeah today it's kind of
it's almost like
like I've had a stroke so one side of my
body is quite strong and and that kind
of carries me and
the left side of my body is kind of
drags a bit
takes a bit more thought to to move and
yeah so that's kind of where I'm at now
but walking every day is it's not too
bad sometimes it's quite hard
but yeah get around all right
and yeah just the pain so
I have a lot of neuropathic pain because
obviously the nerves are all confused so
yeah that's an ongoing thing that I just
kind of have to manage what is that pain
like is it pretty is it pretty painful
like out of ten yeah because your tests
I know like a painter yeah five out of
ten is 10 out of 10 for most people no
it's like it sits around 8 24 7A and
then oh true yeah so bro that's what
because it's kind of a hidden hidden
disability you know if you saw me on the
street you'll think um you know I might
have a tight hammy or something yeah
from my limp but
yeah tailing off all those kind of
unseen things the pain
just the so every step pretty much I
have to consciously think about every
movement yeah
so yeah it's quite it's mentally
draining and even just yeah the pain is
just because it's neuropathic pain is
like something that's hard to explain
something that I hadn't experience until
until I broke my neck
it's kind of it's like fire and ice
and it's just shooting like shooting to
your toes shooting to your to your hands
so yeah it kind of just feels like
like electric pulses
yeah that's I don't know it's hard to
explain but yeah if I could saw bro yeah
you're finding it gradually getting
better or because what it's been what
two years since the or coming up three
three years just just three years
uh how's it getting better
I think
I don't know if it's getting better but
I've been talking to
you know city city at the caves yeah
because he had yeah yeah he had like
pretty very similar injury to me
and he said the pain never really goes
but you kinda
just learn to live and
you you get used to it more resilient
you build more resilience
so yeah just basically just gotta hack
it sure and and that his best thing for
you to do is keep walking on it keep
trying to push it and yeah
so the yeah the worst thing that for for
pain is is the cold for me yeah
so as soon as I get a chill in my body
I'm gone so that's why yeah that was
that was a big factor of moving toraro
was the warm climate
so when I was when I was back for summer
a few if you want to call it that in New
Zealand
but as soon as I got off the plane I
could hardly walk just that cold snap
hit me oh that's right and yeah just a
bit of a nightmare so
yeah it's good to just confirm that yeah
this was the right decision for for me
and
priority is like quality of life and
you know minimizing pain for me and
you know just yeah making making life
more enjoyable and being able to do more
which which I can do over here because
it's you know nice and slow and so
raro's a long-term place for you to live
you obviously wouldn't want to come back
live in New Zealand with the cold
summers
nah um yeah I reckon I in the future I'd
like to you know spend a bit of time
between the two but
base myself here and
kind of pop into New Zealand pop out
so yeah maybe
yeah 50 50 split maybe six months in New
Zealand or something like that but yeah
not really sure yet just yeah okay just
kind of that's that's an Ideal World
here right how good mate good to good to
hear good to get an Insight on to all
that but you know like always I do like
to start these episodes from the start
so we do get the full picture of life as
the legend that you are so take us back
to
um this your sort of childhood and you
grow no you grew up in Auckland and born
and raised yeah what was what was your
childhood like mate we grew up I grew up
in uh onehunga oh yeah it's kind of like
Central and then when I was about 10
parents split up so me and my mum moved
out west and then yeah we've been out
west ever since so
just yeah me my mom and my brothers just
yeah
I was the youngest so oh true how many
brothers did you have so I got two older
brothers oh yeah yeah and I was just I
used to get bullied and then
and then they
they didn't know what they were doing
though they were creating a monster
yeah so now I was just I always I used
to get bullied so badly from near me
just yeah yeah yeah so
and even like growing up by my
because my dad was he was quite hard on
me eh like he was a bit of a old school
so I remember when I used to
like Miss a tackle in the game in a
rugby game yeah [__] this is like what
I'm talking like under eights or
something like about seven years old
yeah uh he'll we'll detour on the way
home to the park with my brother's a
in fact like my dad used to like because
my dad was he was huge he was like six
three one Thirty yeah and uh we just
used to go to the park and then like my
brothers he'll make my brothers running
straight to me
oh and they're like way older than me
and then you know uh we'll stay there
until like I tackled and like my so
they'll all take turns you know the
Myrtle brother my older brother and then
my dad will run at me oh that's fine but
I hated rugby yeah
but yeah that was all right that was
that was traumatic eh but yeah so that's
why and he taught me how to tackle and
all that yeah so obviously for his
technique is a bit old school
I blame him for all the yellow cards
I've received over the years hey
so yeah we'll just we'll just stay at
the park until you know
of somehow like one of my brothers or
like fake that I tackled him and feel
sorry for me it will be like yeah that's
enough go home now
so yeah oh talks okay but nah I probably
wouldn't be the rugby player I was if I
didn't have to yeah I think he was just
trying to harden me up yeah well mate he
definitely did that yeah
it makes a lot of sense with the way you
you played throughout your career but so
you obviously didn't really enjoy
playing rugby if you had the option you
would have you would have not played
yeah
I didn't really like it just because
yeah it was a pretty like I was a gentle
I was a gentle big kid you know
but you know it's kind of got thrown
into rugby and
I kind of I learned to love it probably
at high school when I you know started
to realize [__] like a six six and 120
yeah can do some damage
yeah so yeah I just started you know
enjoying the content enjoying
yeah and I got pretty pretty good which
was you know makes you enjoy it more and
yeah just started making all the all the
teams so I just stuck with it yeah mate
pretty good pretty humble you were you
were a gun
um coming through the grades I know you
did three years at first 15 eh yeah won
the school title Mount grammar so
um mate you had you had huge wraps on
you yeah it was yeah the first 15 was
yeah that was enjoyable at Mount Albert
grammar we had all the boys in that team
like you know Willis was there
all the lands yeah yeah
so well I said y'all were playing there
and yeah we had we had a decent team we
had like Stephen Lord tour was in there
Matt mcgahn and was our 10 yeah
so yeah a lot of a lot of us went on to
to play professionally and
yeah so yeah Willis kind of was the guy
took me under his wing when he was he
was my senior
so he just
yeah came in as a 15 year old and Willis
showed me the ropes gave me my foreign
big broed me come to the room
I didn't even want to drink it he was
like yeah drink this
host
yeah no I love will I say he's he's been
like a big brother to me since then we
played I don't know we just I don't know
we always ended up in the same team
played you know all our Schoolboy he was
always a few years ahead of me but then
ended up playing he playing in Southland
and he came down
at the canes together so
yeah pretty close with Willis he's a
he's a lad yeah did you stay out of
trouble obviously he's been on the
podcast and spoke about sort of all the
stuff he was getting into during his
time at school did you manage to stay
out of all that or did he sort of drag
you in there when he got you drinking
just
he was kind of knowing
I don't know I've seen seen some things
hey uh yeah I'll let it be until he
retired but yeah
but yeah Willis was he was a he was a
tough guy he had a tough upbringing yeah
and yeah he just but he had this real
like
he is he has a soft side where he's like
he's a real protector so he'll look
after if you're his boy
he'll look after you and he's kind of
got you for life so yeah
but now I was me personally now I was
just kind of just struggled of a bit of
drinking yeah yeah drinking was always
the poison for me
and yeah once I once Willis gave me
their wood stuff it was
I loved it
yeah and then you did make like New
Zealand schools is that sort of when you
realize that this is probably
potentially going to be a gig for you
this is going to be your your job yeah
so we it was that they used to have the
New Zealand's under 17s and that's kinda
when I kind of considered oh yeah this
might be a pathway and then I made
schools
and
yeah that was yeah most of the boys from
our schools team ended up you know
playing professional and some in some
way
but yeah that was when I started taking
it seriously
and really wanted to make it a career
but yeah yeah then i s from there I
signed I signed down in Southland yeah
why'd you go Southland yeah because
obviously Auckland would have been
wanting you yeah yeah to other provinces
as well why'd you choose Southland
so but I've grown up our West Auckland
a lot of the boys like a couple years
older than me you know gun players
but same as me they made New Zealand
schools or something and then they went
into the Auckland Academy and then you
know just fizzled out or you know just
just did it kick on and
you know it's so easy to fall through
the cracks in Auckland yeah
because there's always that Knicks New
Zealand schools or New Zealand 20s
player coming
and yeah a lot of my friends older than
me had had done that fallen through the
cracks and
I just knew like like I I would because
yeah I was you know
I was still I was still a kid and I
don't know if I had the discipline to
you know
crack it in Auckland at that at that age
when they were so there's so many
distractions in Auckland
so I thought you know me and my mum
actually we thought it'll be better
to move somewhere else and
yeah so I moved as far far away from
Auckland
I've probably never been to invercargill
in my life and just
that was a culture shocking yeah yeah
right as far as away from all the
distractions as possible yeah what was
it what was it like when you got there
just most just the straight culture
shock yeah because I was down there with
uh remember Cardiff Cardiff yeah yeah
yeah so it's me and him we went down
together
and we were just literally the only
brown people in invercargill that sort
of felt like
says
it was just you know we could feel
people staring at us when we were
walking around like what
these guys aren't from here
yeah it was just I I enjoyed Southland
because well it taught me
I kind of filled the holes in in my game
because I was I was like a
just a big popper you know I could run
run the ball and
and make hits
but down in South and is is where I
learned
you know how to grind out a 80 and just
you know I just had to add a bit of grit
to my game because you have to work you
have to work for everything down down
south they don't have the talent pool
uh like like Auckland so
you know they're hard work beats Talent
kinda
kind of place and yeah they they're the
ones that yeah
I think they
that's where I learned a lot and realize
you know
rugby is not about their highlight hit
or you know bumping off someone which is
what we were
what we used to think was everything
yeah in Auckland yeah you know just kind
of respect the game more and
playing next to guys like John Hardy and
Tim boys yeah like rather just the
Battlers of battles Jason Rutledge oh
the workhorses he's by just it's
inspirationally just on the field of
them just
yeah a bit out of breath just grunting
yeah just carry on and they're just I
don't know they just they don't stop
those boys and yeah
I think I did take a bit away from you
know just being around guys like that
right that's so cool and you probably
fit in off the field too um down there
though obviously all love the lovely
purse so um you would have had a few
good all right that was the thing hey
because I was I needed I was like oh no
I'm gonna make all these dramatic
changes in my life I want to pursue it
but I went sobering oh I did yeah I
apprecially out of school I had a season
sober oh good on you bro I didn't like
it didn't work for me yeah
I'm not like a
drunk but I just
yeah it took me a few years to kind of
get the balance right because
yeah if I was I realized when I was too
like diligent if I just focus too much
on the footy and you know dedicated the
life to it yeah I was terrible eh or
just
yeah and then when I used to
have a bit of a balance like you know
toxic Tuesday night
foreign just you know lit my hair down
now in the DNA yeah that's what worked
for me personally
so I just you know getting that balance
took me a while so
yeah but it took it did take a while
because you know we were sober and then
on it all the time then the season and
then you know found a little found a
balance oh yeah this is what works for
me and when you found that balance
that's when you uh got your super
contract right yeah years later and the
Keynes Came Calling what was that like
no I was exciting because I was turning
into a bit of a islander's development
Veterinary
oh
you're like yeah have a little game and
again ashburton or something like random
town and
and you're on your way back to
invercargill so
yeah I was yeah I was cutting on the
fringes for the for the Landers for a
year for years
and I never really eventuated to
anything and
so I moved home to Auckland and and yeah
then I made the canes straight away so
but yeah I don't I didn't really change
much of my my playing I don't know what
it was it just kind of
the right timing I guess but
I reckon
I don't know it's a bit bit of the gate
but I reckon I was
I made Super Rugby when I grew my hair
really true I don't know because I kind
of had the shot back in size for years
you know just just looked like every
other dude on the field and I started to
stand out a bit when I when I grew my my
hair out and more noticeable yeah my
first year my first year old Vlog here I
made Super Rugby so all right there's
like
if you think of guys like Dan Pryor do
you remember him yeah yeah all right
when he had the short back and sides
you know he was just battling out
Northland and all the Auckland and then
dreads started killing it sure I reckon
it is a thing yeah yeah
look at Mata and um
you're here
right that's that's good advice anyone
who's feeling like they're not getting
noticed just growing here just do
something drastic
change your look drastically and oh yeah
you'll get a look do you move home put
on the blue and white Hoops grow your
hair out get A hurricane's contract move
down to Wellington and then what was
that like for you going down there and
um being a part of that side yeah so
yeah I went down on the On A hurricane's
wider Squad contract oh were you wider
yeah yeah I was a wider wild Squad oh
that's true yeah me like
yeah all of us ended up playing though
but yeah we'll get to that about
pre-season was I always struggled with
Fitness like during my career yeah not
so much on the field like all that stuff
but more just testing yo-yos I was a bit
of a you know
15 16 kind of guy
and yeah I always struggled with that
that aspect and
you know it's hard to you know show you
can play when you're when your numbers
aren't looking
good at that level
so yeah I remember after a few weeks
me and um Tonga bear were like
we're we're caking it during Fitness
and we're just honestly we are it was a
joke I just I don't know I couldn't
I was just getting left behind at
Fitness but I came
second to last on the on the surf to
Peak
but I would have been last if it wasn't
do you remember how we had that Young
The Young Academy
young Academy like his name was Louis
law Manu oh yeah yeah yeah and he yeah
he like did like way worse than me so
you know no one remembers that
I was the last contracted
I came last out of all the contracted
players and you know so shout out to
Louis before
keeping me out of the history books
but yeah back to me and me and Tonga
bear
so
um boydy caught us into the to his
office
and I was boydy and plums
and Waddy yeah and they
they just sat us down and just said you
know we
we bought you guys over here to
you know because we thought you guys
were ready for Super Rugby and
just the past few weeks you ever been
showing
showing your worth and you know you
don't don't look like you belong here
yeah me and Tonga bear were just we'll
pissed off hey because you know we we
knew that we could cut it at Super Rugby
but
our numbers might not have looked like
it but when you are on field ability was
was at their level so
but yeah this this session uh this
meeting that we had was
um it was just before a contact session
so you know me and bear walked out of
their office and we were like pissed off
like you know he was like doco
foreign
we just looked at each other before the
session like gave each other the nod and
bro we just started ending like people
just taking names of all the Vets at the
canes and
yeah anyone that rants us we were just
folding their million after that
um you know what he came up to me and he
was like yeah you know
see because he was the one that actually
like wanted to sign me at the canes and
I was he put his name on the line
and he came up to me he's like yeah
that's that's why I [__] signed you
boy he's like yeah we need that every
every training and then yeah body and
plums ended up liking me after that
and yeah right that's crazy I ended up
getting a proper crack from just yeah
folding a few guys at training at a
contact session so
it was good because they
because I was good in the contact area
they were able to you know ignore the 16
yo-yo and you know just
just give me a crack because I was I
just need like I just needed a 80 and a
180 blowout and then I'm usually sweet
I can do all the Mas running and and
just have no effect on me but yeah so
that's I was happy when you know
conditioning game started becoming a
thing because
yeah they're all good for me
but
yeah and then what was it hurricane
2016.
yeah I wasn't I was
yeah I only got caught in because it was
it was broady because he had that
concussion so I was there as as I was
there as kind of injury cover
and bro he was but he was unruly so
once he decided to
to hang up hang up the boots
you know that I kind of moved to the
fifth string lock
and you know I was getting a few rips
now so
and then Christian Lloyd
um the lock yeah he he did his
his knee wasn't recovering so he he hung
up the boots
so then I was I moved up to you know
four five ranks yeah so I was like wow I
was like might have a shot to play here
yeah
and then it was
and then so the starters were
Mark Everett yeah elbow that's right
blade was playing lock and Via was the
third
so yeah first few games
um
ever was starting and killing it
and you know blade he's gonna be played
Just he was killing it too so
you know we had that
we got pumped from the brumbies and that
yeah remember that first round yeah yeah
so we're pretty all right first few
rounds were struggling and then but Abba
was playing 80s just a few weeks in a
row and then
they did the old give them a rest week
ones and
and yeah so me and Via got the start and
then
yeah it was the old you know have a rest
weekend then no these guys are starting
now so yeah that was
that was that was pretty
cool because me and Via were
both rookies
and then yeah we ended up starting every
game
I remember I just I just wanted to play
well 10 games because that's what you
needed as a wider Squad to get that
bonus yeah
if I was like playing injured just [__]
just hacking it yeah because I wanna I
needed that 10 just for
times are harder but
yeah all of us like all of us wider
Squad they were always chicken yeah bro
yeah how many games are you on yeah it
was me Jameson
um Willis you would you would have all
got there right because you you guys all
played a massive part yeah yeah we did
we all we all ended up getting a bonus
and we were so happy
and then
yeah so
yeah it was bro that was a special year
2016.
we I don't know what it was it was just
kind of
I feel like everyone had a bit of a chip
on their shoulder
everyone as individuals had you know
different things they were playing for
and I don't know just collectively it
clicked and
yeah we just went on that run and
and ended up winning so yeah that was a
special year and
yeah special for myself just because I
felt like I got their validation that
you know I'd been seeking as a rugby
player just
and just that you know knowing for
myself that yes I can I can play at this
level and I can play a while so
yeah that was a that was a special year
for me was your old man um
what was he like watching your games and
stuff was he always you know how he said
he was like rough yeah um as a young
fella was he the same all the way
through your and professional career as
well nah so yeah that was kind of more
when I was young
it was when he kind of that's when he
was talking like used to do the old
random straight challenge with me
but
yeah as we kind of grew apart as I got a
bit older
so I didn't really see much of him from
you know maybe High School oh sure and
yeah we just kind of fell out of context
so
but yeah I know that he he used to watch
my games and
yeah that was part of my
yeah I had those kind of those father
issues so I was always
trying to become what you know I know he
he was trying to create and you know
just that was my
sort of mindset was you know I'm just
gonna go out here and be a grub because
you know I want my I hope my dad's
watching yeah
yeah you can you'll see them so yeah I
know that I got told that he he did he
did watch all my games because he passed
away last year oh true
yeah you know that was that was tough to
deal with because
you know we had we never really got to
chop it up and
and like you know piece it out but
yeah just talking with you know his his
new misses in there and I I found out
that he had all my games recorded on on
my sky and so he was he was proud of me
which was yeah it was it's not the same
as
you know making peace and
because you know everyone just wants
wants a relationship with their father
but yeah that was quite quite a tough
thing and
yeah that's why yeah I think I always
struggled with like older men
you know having authority over me
because
and like telling me what to do so you
know I was always kind of
it took a lot for
for me to trust
trust coaches like older men
and that's why
that's why I was so close of um
Richard what what he because he he like
took the time to you know understand me
as a person and
just yeah showed a bit of empathy and
just gave me time and it built my trust
so yeah that's why I would have done
anything for water yeah that's cool it's
so it is so powerful ways before coaches
yeah yeah connect on that deeper level
and is it sort of where your lack of
conditioning like you spoke about before
hater being told by trainers what to do
or that you had to get to this line at
that certain point or was that all part
of it as well
uh I don't think it was that that side
effect of the training it was more the
like the rugby side of things yeah
but here the the fitness was just
I don't know I managed to after years to
just you know start hitting a 17-1 17-2
so
that was just just good enough so yeah
pass yeah let's just I don't know I
don't know I just like a lot of people
that are more uh bigger boys or you know
power athletes struggle with with yo-yos
or yeah or Broncos or
yeah yeah I was I ended up having to
like trade down to
like I don't know I was I was playing
real light just to get just to get that
yo-yo so yeah
I can yeah
right there's like there's sort of one
thing I always remember about you was
like you were so chilled so cruisy off
the field but I don't think I ever met a
player who had the biggest like flick of
the switch when they crossed that line
and played like
um you like in the German stuff you were
just chilled you you could tell you
didn't really care about lifting weights
but once you got onto that field man
like you said you you just transformed
into some like Mad Warrior who could
just kill people and fold people uh I
think yeah that was
yeah as soon as I like got into game
situations I don't know I just used to
flick the switch and
just take out you know
all the trauma from my life out on the
opposition is I don't know pretty toxic
but
I just you know I just used to
enjoy just being you know a grub like
just you know smashing people and
so yeah I enjoyed that
I could you know just be chilled off the
field and then once I got on there I
knew
it was a job to do so you did two more
years at the canes and then you ended
decided to head over to Worcester
um yeah what was that what was the
reason behind that move
uh
money yeah just yeah
yeah I'll just
Super Rugby was you know
that was good I I loved it I wanted to
stay at the canes but
you know when they're when you're
getting offers that
you know double or triple what you're on
yeah
it's hard to say no especially you know
I wanted to get some Financial backing
and you know set myself up so I was at a
good age still still quite Young
so I could I could demand a decent
contract because of that
um
and yeah Worcester came to the table I
remember I was
it was ended up being Worcester or the
Scarlets or the two that yeah
but then
yeah just
uh I just ended up yeah wanting to play
in the English Premiership
because I just got on that barbarians
tour and and we stayed in England and
London and
yeah I just I loved it over in England
and
just wanted to be
you know around that that sort of
so yeah move to a Worcester
and yeah we were we struggled there
we're uh
kind of like yeah similar to like when
you're at
um Irish yeah you know we're a kind of
French Prim team yeah all right
you know at the start of the season it's
you know we'll make a statement and then
this is going to be the year that they
should we show
that Worcester is here to stay and then
you know halfway through the season week
okay calculating how to stay up in the
premium how many bonus points we need so
so yeah it was just I don't know it was
tough because you know we weren't one of
those you know big traditional English
clubs
but yeah well we had some good players
and good young players and well I
enjoyed it I enjoyed playing with with
some of the people I played off there
um but yeah we just we couldn't get it
together on field and yeah we'll just I
remember we were we were like those
random teams that would
will randomly beat saracens and then
get get pumped by Newcastle at home the
next week so that's right
you never really knew how like what
Worcester was going to show up so
yeah we were just so inconsistent but
uh there was there was a lot of guns in
that team and
a lot of the young boys you know
they were just freaks like some of the
18 19 year olds coming through so
you know so it's nice to I Mentor some
of them and
and play experience English rugby how
was your footy over there did you find
the
um style of rugby suited your game yeah
because I don't have to be as fit over
there yeah so I kind of could revert
back to my natural body size
and still still get around fine so
yeah I think it did it did suit me a bit
more
and but oh it's quite it's a hard
composition I just
it's not as expansive but the the tight
play and
and defending long phases is it's hard
every week is a is a hard game and the
prim right tough to be a Ford I reckon
like what was you like were you guys
heaps of mauling and heaps of set piece
during the work you would have been
loving it
just the astro turf was the issue oh
that's right yeah yeah so
then the knees were and hips go when
you're doing 100 lineups a week
and props are just dropping you yeah so
yeah everyone like had had knee ankle
hip problems
and yeah I don't know just
hey dude you don't like Ashes to say
it's like it must not be good for your
hips too no they were no good for my hip
yeah because all of Matt Brooks work was
done for nothing hey after playing on it
what a surgeon a what a surgeon
shout out to Matt breakfast
and then obviously the big incident 4th
of January yeah man talk me through this
like um life-changing neck injury but
yeah what do you remember about the
whole incident
well I just so we were playing series
away
in London so
yeah it was just I was on the bench and
I you know it was we were kind of we
were tanking that game to be honest like
you know we just
I wasn't meant to play that game
and they just boiled me down sat on the
bench and they said you know we're not
really going to put you on so
then we were getting pumped and they
decided to Chuck me on to you know try
and restore some pride and my first
Carry I just you know
I got it and we were
because we were playing their old
set up the box kick from everywhere ones
and
we're on like halfway and but we're
setting up a box okay so I took the
carry
and just as soon as I I made contact you
know I think I got a hip to my my head
up to the top of the head and just
Whiplash back
and yeah as soon as I connected my whole
body just shut down so but it was it was
scary yeah yeah so I was kind of and I
was I was laying on my front so
and the ball was underneath me so
but I was just you know lump and they
called they stopped the game and I was
like kind of trying to stay calm and I I
knew I just knew that it was what city
had I just I don't know what it was but
I was like oh [__] this must be you know
what happened to city has just happened
to me all right yeah yeah so
Yeah just they had to I took like an
hour
they had to
turn me over obviously without damaging
my neck further get me on the stretcher
and I was starting to like you know be
calm and then
I didn't realize when you injure your
spinal cord like everything below is
affected like even internally
so yeah I started panicking when I when
I stopped I stopped breathing eh so
because my yeah my lung wasn't wasn't
functioning
so I stopped breathing and I started
panicking they had to get me on the
oxygen and I was like kind of
In and Out Of Consciousness just because
I couldn't I couldn't really breathe so
that was pretty that was scary it's just
kind of gasping for breath and that
um
and then yeah I just knew it was but it
was tough times ahead because
I could just tell and then you know
they got me in the hospital
just I was lucky it was in London
because I went to one of the best
hospitals at St Mary's Hospital in
London
and then got had to I don't know door
the tests and all that
and yeah they saw like
all the damage I had done to my neck but
I had to go on those MRI machines but I
was in there for like three hours before
skin yeah what's the pain like at this
time is this like excruciating pain no
the pain kind of kicked in when I when I
got to the hospital oh yeah so just like
when it first happened uh I think just
numb yeah yeah and then that's then once
I got to the hospital a few hours later
that's when I started getting the
neuropathic
like it was kind of like electric
electricity through my body oh yeah Fire
and Ice and it was just unbearable hey
so
yeah just
from there
there were
there were Bowers and um what's it
called ICU for a couple weeks and and
then they decided to go in and do my
do my surgery on my neck and try and
stabilize it
and yeah that was I think it was like 10
hours or something they spin in there
and then yeah what I woke up
just in so much pain and I panicked when
I woke up from surgery because
because they what they do is they they
cut through your your neck from the
front
and they kind of move your vocal cords
and then operate on your vertebrae
through there
so it was nalia
yeah so yeah after that surgery
I couldn't eat or drink
and I couldn't talk for like a month
because they damaged my
my vocal cords when when they when they
were doing surgery
so I just yeah so that was tough because
[__] I was like lying there on my back
paralyzed yeah I can't can't eat can't
drink can't talk
so I can't you know signal out to the
nurse fully helpless how did you
communicate you just couldn't yeah just
kind of like I had I could you know I
had a bit of a
like a Darren lock your voice so I could
kind of you know
give them a couple words here and there
yeah but yeah it took a while to get my
voice back and
yeah I remember just losing it at this
doctor eh because
they put me on a
a morphine
morphine pump you know you like press it
every time that you you need it and he
just got me all set up like this cocky
ass doctor he's like got me set up
and he was like yeah mate you know
whenever you're in pain doesn't Comfort
yeah you just squeeze us here and he
showed me and
and you know the pain relief will come
and then I just looked at him I was like
wow
I [__] [__] paralyzed bro I can't
[__] push anything
you just like all right heaps of that
sort of stuff you know they'll just
forget that I'm I can't move anything
yeah so but that was bro that was so
traumatic being in hospital that was for
that first month and a half
because they had to they had to turn me
every two hours because otherwise you'll
get no pressure sores and all that
so just no no real sleep or
or anything just just lying there
counting the the dots and the lines on
the roof
and yeah it was just but it was tough
and then they'll try me on all these
different
medications for my pain because nothing
was doing anything
and yeah they ended up getting me on
like all the hard stuff like morphine
Fentanyl
and then bro I was on ketamine for a
couple weeks I said that horse
tranquilizer stuff yes I was like just
relaxing in the k-hole
but yeah even though I was like it was
just kind of buzzing me out yeah and I
was in hospital but
pain wise still had no effect
yeah
so crazy that was that was a struggle
yeah but the thing that helped and while
the nurses ended up because they ended
up bending the rules for me and allowing
me to have like
20 plus visitors
because the nurses and the doctors
notice that when the boys will come
through to the hospital and they were
chatting and like making me laugh and
you know just forget like playing around
with my arms yeah
that you know I wouldn't I wouldn't be
like
requesting pain meds and like or almost
distract me yeah it's so cool laughter
truly is the the best medicine like they
say
yeah right let's let's go and did you
often think about before you were
talking about like you know you weren't
supposed to even get on the field you
were supposed to go to that game you
were supposed to play dude were you
thinking about that as you lay there do
you still think about it now like what
if like why why didn't why'd they put me
on
I'll try I try not to because
I don't want to you know those kind of
thoughts will eat you up forever and
yeah you know it is what it is it
happened so
you know no one's got a time machine so
I can't dwell on on thoughts like that
those Waters
I just yeah early on I just
you know made the decision yet it
happened
no I need these are the cards I've been
dealt and you know how I responders
is what matters now and when they told
you obviously they told you for the
first time that you're potentially
wheelchair wheelchair bound for
um life
um yeah what are you thinking what are
you feeling in those times
but I just I I just ignored it because
we had this big meeting with the doctors
and all the surgeons
and they you know set oh the guy was
already lying down but they set them
down
and they said
you know
Michael's going to be you know in a
wheelchair
like electric wheelchair and we'll need
you know 24-hour assistance for the rest
of his life
and but they obviously upset know that
but I know I just kind of I just a bit
of it was like I was in denial but
I you know I just
my wife always laughs about it because
when they said you know serious has
conversation and they're like you know
Michael you're gonna be in a wheelchair
for life and
so prepare to need care for the rest of
your life and bro I just I just looked
at a doctor and again I go Naji and he
kept like he goes he goes no your spinal
cord is it's damaged you're you're
quadripedic and like a Naji not me
because like oh I was wondering if I I
was on the walking and I was like Najee
I just everything they said I was going
nah dude that's not me well you didn't
know me and that was kind of my mindset
like throughout the whole thing it's
like nah dude not me yeah so
so I was just you know I just knew
like I don't know there was something
just I just refused to believe it and I
was like nah that's not me that I'm like
[__] I don't want that and then yeah I
remember
it was
I was just kinda
I used to like try and meditate and when
I was lying there paralyzing I'll just
try and focus and like visualize
but
the brain signals that I need to to move
my fingers or toes and I'll just sit
there for hours just like
visualizing you know this my spinal cord
and
like the messages getting sent all the
way to my my hands and I but it was
powerful stuffy and
and then you know one day I was off I
was with my wife and I just asked her to
hold my hand up so I could see it so she
was holding my hand and I was just kind
of did the whole
focus and visualize myself moving and
then like my finger started to flicker a
little bit
and though that's all I needed there was
that little bit of Hope and I was like
yeah I was like [__] these doctors I'm
on I'm gonna walk yeah yeah as soon as
you felt your finger flick you knew yeah
I was like but I was like but that's all
the hope I need like it was a tiny bit
of Hope but I just clung onto that hope
for dear life and I just ran off I was
like yeah I was that's why I was like I
was cocky after that I was like I can
see I told these doctors no me no me
dude yeah see my finger flickering I was
like oh see quadriplegic not even yeah
ever here else I was
and that's kinda when I started just I
just blocked everything out and like
just focused on rehab and then you know
the finger moved that kind of progressed
into you know being able to move my arm
move my toe that kind of
just kept progressing and you know I'll
just consciously try and
move everything and
yeah I remember the thing is when I
first got that
got their um their hand moving I made my
nurse like
stand there like the whole night no
sleep every five minutes I'll show you
my hand and I'll just like make sure
that I could still move it if I was
scared if I went to sleep that that I
wake up and I couldn't move that finger
all right so just sleepless nights
and yeah so I just focused on
trying to move and
but it was
like well you wouldn't wish it upon your
worst enemy what I went through is just
the pain and
like how tough mentally it was but
I just I just dedicated my whole life my
whole being to
just rehabbing and
because I'm you know I'm fighting for
quality of life I'm not you know it's
different now I'm not really having to
get back on the field it's it's rehab
for you know what life's gonna look like
and that's that's a you know it's a
strong motivating factor and
and yeah just kind of drove me every day
I was just grinding
because I think after a month and a half
at that hospital I went to the
Rehabilitation Unit
I was just outside a
um outside of London
and yeah from there I was just so six
hours a day I'll put in work
just all different types of things
occupational therapy physio
hydrotherapy just so six hours every day
and
uh well I was just so determined well
like but I'm like I'm proud of myself
for how I just
and I blocked everything out and
and just [__] bro I just sent it in
like my rehab was
it was crazy the
the physios and
occupational therapists and doctors they
they just said they've never seen
anything like it like
just the way I was how driven I was to
to walk and you know be independent
so yeah I still keep in contact before
man like physios and that sort of stay
and
uh they'll always tell me that you're
the type of
patient is
you're the type of patient you know that
I'm the type of patient is why they they
got into the their line of work and
seeing stories like mine
because bro there was like a
there's like a seven percent chance that
I would you know move again so
yeah it was it was Against All Odds
and you know a bit of it was
but if it was luck you know the spinal
cord matter
being able to
get some signals down but I put a lot of
it down to just grit and
just just being tough like [__] like
but I reckon I'm the toughest person I
know hey just after going through there
right and yeah it was just so yeah six
hours for
so I was at hospital all up six six
months
and that was
that was during covert too so a lot of
the time I was just in there by myself
no visitors
and well just every day like clockwork
and
six hours a day every day
and yeah who was
it was it was tough but yeah I'm glad
I'm glad that I you know put in that
work because
right
right today I'm thinking
thanking myself for
for just knuckling down and putting in
their work man it's so cool to hear I'm
I was getting Goosebumps half basically
through that whole the whole way you're
speaking there man that is so crazy so
cool to hear
um your determination mate you should be
so proud of what you've done but you
sort of mentioned your uh
mental health and how how you're
thinking on the on the table and stuff
you must have had some bad days
um some setbacks where did it get to how
did you stay so driven were there days
where you just felt like you wanted to
give up or where'd you get to what was
the worst days like
oh so
I reckon those six months my mental
health I knew
I knew that it was something I was
I was it was affecting me a lot but I
just chose not to acknowledge my mental
health during that period
and I don't know it was like at the time
I I think I just needed to
that was my mentality was oh just deal
with the mental health stuff later
because I need to just focus on
just grinding it was
because the more like you grind in that
period the more you know movement you'll
get back and
the quality of life will be
will be improved
so it's not until I left Hospital
and went back to my like normal life
is when you know
all the depression post-traumatic stress
disorder
you know that stuff started to really
affect me and
you know I'm I'm still in I'm still in
therapy but
it's just going to be a ongoing thing
because yeah especially when I when I
moved back to to Auckland from the UK is
when
you know it's been a really
started affecting me I was having
I was just depressed and like had
anxiety going places
and you know the PTSD is like something
that's
yeah it just kind of sneaks up on you
hey
just get random
flashbacks to to being on the field or
being in hospital
and then
you know your mind can't tell if it's if
it's really happening or not and you
know so you just feel like you're back
in that moment and it's real it's real
tough
so yeah that's why
when I got back to Auckland I
me and my wife because we were both like
struggling mentally
it was just a big adjustment to life and
in Auckland just wasn't the place for us
to do it like to to find find my fear
again and you know get used to this new
body this new life
so
yeah both are therapists
recommended you know we we needed a
change of Lifestyle
to help with my mental health both of
our Mental Health
so we just yeah we made the dramatic
lifestyle change and moved here which
has been you know a place that I feel
like
I've finally been able to you know get
some healing in and
you know just
just like have some time for myself to
breathe because everything was just so
overwhelming coming out of Hospital
I'm trying to like figure out what what
my new normal is
and it's just you know it was too too
busy and
yeah just I would get overwhelmed and
just just chill at home
whereas over here I'm out of the house
more and the sun the sun does a lot for
your mental health yeah but yeah that's
why I just that's why I kind of
I went off the grid a bit was just I had
to focus on
put my mental health first first
um yeah that's why yeah sorry about
didn't reply to you for about a good
year
but yeah I just I just had to it was
tough because you know I felt like I was
being a
being a bad bad friend to people and bad
family but but I had to just look after
myself and and in that year and that
moment
because yeah I just wasn't feeling
feeling good at all
and
yeah so moving here to the Cook Islands
here I love this I love this place now
and
and it is a second home that has allowed
me to
to heal and
just you know figure out what life's
going to look like post injury
and yeah just
you know I feel like there's there's not
a lot of pressure here which is
something that is a big burden lifted
you know I just go about my my day at my
own pace
and you know everything kind of moves at
a slow pace
which is perfect for me
all right this is so cool and you like
you mentioned your mental health and
during all this time you've also got the
added I guess pressure or unnecessary
pressure coming from Worcester at the
time around how the whole who's going to
pay for your treatment and all this sort
of stuff happening how much did this
weigh on you yeah that was big
especially
like they didn't pay my bill and
so they paid four weeks of my stay and
then
the rest of my stay was so maybe
three or four months of this day was was
unpaid for
and you know I started getting the bills
from the hospital
[Music]
which was like stressful at the time
because I'm
you know just trying to focus on
rehabbing and I'm like oh [__] like
hundreds of thousands of dollars who's
paying for this yeah yeah
and then yeah so and it didn't get paid
and like I never got paid I was just
lucky that the hospital I was at
you know Royal the Royal buckinghamshire
Hospital
in Aylesbury they just
did me a solid pretty much and sure you
know yeah
because I was you know the hospital
director I was I we all became quite
close during that covered period because
we were all locked in
and he or he just did me a solid so
I was so grateful for that but yeah I
was just I was gutted because I mean by
I wrote a tweet like
just
but I was a little bit cut but I was
hard to get but I wrote a tweeted and I
was like oh hopefully what's the Pain by
hospital bills this year and but they
they did it and then they put out the
statement just gaslighting me just
saying oh
you know this and that saying just
pretty much making me look like a liar
so you know it's sad that all this stuff
has come out now and the clubs went
under but
I'm kinda I'm kind of glad that happened
because
you know
I try to be a person a love of integrity
and honesty and you know I was keeping
it 100 and and and they made me out to
look like a liar so
when everything comes to light I was I
knew it would eventually come but
but yeah it was just
it was quite you know relieving because
it was quite relieving because I I knew
that yes I was like and people knew like
yeah you actually was telling the truth
right that is that's crazy so when you
found out that Worcester was no longer a
club and there's no surprises for you
just the way it was run as is that sort
of how you felt yeah as a playing group
we kind of you could you could see the
the cracks when they changed ownership
because we had this Old owner when I
first got there his name was Cecil
Duckworth and he was just he was like
The Godfather he was the daughter yeah
just loved the club it was like his baby
had time for all the boys you know he'll
he'll pull up to all our change and
Shake everyone's hand and he just looked
after looked after the club and looked
after us and then
yeah these these two owners came in and
you know they were they were quite
arrogant like the way they talked and
you know the way they walked around and
you know all the you know you could tell
just things weren't weren't going right
at the club
and
yeah especially during that covert
period because
it just yeah yeah I don't want to I
don't really want to you know dog the
club for spot yeah but like I loved it
at Worcester and
yeah and like I'm glad that that
happened but
yeah that was it was a long time coming
and I'm glad it did it that it did
happen because
you know this
there's no Club in the premium now and
you know what's this lovely town and we
had the best supporters so I'm just
feeling for all the boys you know all
the a lot of the players you know out of
pocket they're just
you know had multi-year deals and you
know they just stopped getting paid so
yeah they owed hundreds of thousands of
dollars
so you know a lot of people have been
you know lives have been changed through
you know whatever the dealings that
Worcester were
and and yeah that's a sad thing because
you know it was such a good club it was
sad it's a shame to see in WASP
obviously as well it went down but yeah
seemed to be coming back but do you have
any sort of hard feelings against rugby
do you
how do you how do you view rugby now do
you watch it yeah what's your thoughts
on the game
I'm not like a rugby nut or anything but
yeah you know I'll watch a few
highlights here and there
still you know keep track of you know
old mates that are playing
so you have to see how they're playing
and doing but
yeah it's a it's a tough one because
you know rugby gave me everything
but I also you know took away everything
so
you know it's like
it's a tough one to process because you
know I wouldn't be the person I am
without rugby but also the game is you
know
it's took it took away a lot and you
know my body's for life so
like playing rugby is is going to
wherever I did during my career
and the injury was going to affect me
for the rest of my life so
yeah that's tough to answer that one
yeah and so
like at one of the videos that I
remember you posting where
um made me laugh especially early on was
one of the ones where you were I guess
just starting to walk
um and you have your big fall I'll talk
to me about that and was that sort of
what the recovery process was like yeah
no it was just because I was always
trying to push the boundary in my
physios
like I was bossing it just I always try
and do more than I could yeah
and so I was walking I got to a point
where I could walk with two crutches oh
yeah
and then the physio is like
Mike will keep you on two crutches I
want you to get used to this
and then for just me being Bots just I
said
Naji
one crutch I reckon I can do it around
one crutch and he was like oh and then
he was like no I don't I don't want you
to do that I was like nah I'm doing it
just yeah no I wasn't hearing anyone hey
just not just so determined
and then so that's why that's why I was
getting filmed because I was like I was
so confident that I could do it yeah I
was like babe film this and watch this
one crutch started walking I was like
going well and then
you know about five steps in just
tripped up fell on my face like
physio tried to catch me and I [__]
bumped him off and we were just a rock
on the floor and for everyone like
because everyone in the rehab since I
was watching it I was so embarrassed
part
you're like [__] because all the other
patients are like I could tell they
wanted to laugh and I was like [__]
yeah so that was like all right that was
that was a that was the joke of the
hospital for a few weeks there it was
like I should have listened to those
yeah
did that do any damage those sort of
Falls or was it not it's just
it's all good nah
it's kind of oh
made a career out of falling on the
ground so yeah true just kind of felt
yeah didn't feel like anything yeah and
was it anything that like when you
obviously you can't walk but um
you're also not playing the game anymore
does it was there anything that you
missed about you know guys talk about
how hard it is when they retire but
yours is like
yours is the ultimate yeah forced to
retire you can't move
um did you miss anything about the game
or what what parts of the game did you
miss
um
yeah I do I've started missing it a lot
actually it's just
just being around mates every day that's
that's the camaraderie is what I miss a
lot yeah
and just you know
we all just hang around
Tuesday night's always fun toxic Tuesday
and yeah but even just you know being
able to
you know express myself using my body
it's hard not being able to do that and
you know letting frustration out through
playing the game of rugby
not having that
it's kind of trying to find other ways
to
uh you know cope with
I like stressful times and you know
stress in your life because you can't
just go hit a rock now yeah kinda you
know
have to use other avenues to
to de-stress what do you use
well I like
I love I just love
going into the ocean over here so every
day
I'm in the I'm in the water and yeah
just I just think it's healing for me
because being in the water
I can I can move normally and
I don't have to worry about you know
balancing or oh true or trying to yeah
so so can you swim yeah yeah I can swim
and you're not gonna pretty much run
like I can run in water
so yeah with like a life jacket or just
nothing with nothing to tap your float
no I could just just swim bro yeah sweet
yeah so
yeah I like I like being in in the ocean
and water because yeah because I feel
you know almost free free from my body
and able to
to do things of minimal effort rather
than having to consciously
I think of every movement right swimming
that's it Paralympics
that's a low-key goal of my name
I'd like to find an event that you know
I could excel at
and just give it a crack but
yeah it's hard over here I'd have to
come back to New Zealand for a little
bit which yeah I want to I want to look
at doing this year maybe just to give
some different pair of sports a go and
see see what I'm what I'm good at
because
um
injury last time I'm still
like like you know pretty pretty strong
for like quadriplegic and yeah I'd love
to just you know train towards something
rather than you know I'm just rehabbing
you know just for
just for the sake of that I'd like to
have a goal yeah that'd be cool what
have you looked into any sports yeah
yeah like that you could do so I'm
interested in
you know throwing
because I'd be in a seated seated throw
or uh oh yeah or like a you know seated
shot put or discus
even even cycling like
yeah because I can I can ride a bike and
I'm still pretty decent on a what bike
so surf to peek all over yeah mate I
want Redemption
yeah so oh
I'd like to to give it a go but you know
just a bit of admin at the moment yeah
so this year I'm looking to plan
once I've settled in oh mate you got
plenty of time on your side how old are
you now are you 30 yeah just turned 30.
yeah
yeah let's see you know life life starts
at 30 they reckons yeah that's it I hope
that's not a yarn
but as always we've gone to our
Instagram for some questions and mate a
lot of those guys you've mentioned have
come in here uh come up trumps with some
questions say well we'll roll through
this before we finish but and what a
podcast has been okay first question ask
him if he is the toughest quadriplegic
foreign
okay next one next question is who is
your favorite teammate to play alongside
favorite teammate bro there's a few
I can't really say one but yeah guys
like
Ricky riccatelli he was my bestie and
Wally
he's a lad
um
it's holding a beer yeah
Sam Losi oh Lads Love loved Vince
Russell yeah Milani yeah Milani Nano
yeah he was a good dude in Worcester
yeah Bryce him Bryce him was a was a lad
right
um and yeah I had a good friend over at
Worcester Joe tougher to he's a hooker
for
for the USA team oh yeah yeah so yeah I
don't know there's a lot there's a lot
I've made a lot of good friends through
rugby and
and yeah so I that was what I enjoyed
the most I was having those those strong
friendships yeah it is the coolest part
of the game eh the connections and the
people you meet along the journey and
especially when you play over in
different countries and stuff how you
experience all these
um different cultures and you meet all
these different people and connections
you keep for the rest of your life which
is so cool facts okay next one how
important is Carver Club this must be
one of your railro mates
ah
kava Club yes so
just something that started and
it's just been it's kind of replaced my
toxic Tuesday
which was a which was a big void in my
life
so just a few just a few local boys from
around the island and
I was lucky enough to be invited in and
and you know they've shown me love and
saw me around the island and kind of
given me that bit of local knowledge
which which you need when you're moving
to to a new country
so yeah that's that's an important part
of my my week now and and it's
yeah it helps a lot with you know mental
health and that just
on the covers just chopping it up having
some
having some Yarns and yeah so yeah
there's my boys over here and I love
them how good this guy might one of them
might have asked this question too ask
him about his only friend
he's
um
his tomati's first cousin oh is he oh
it's true yeah yeah yeah he must be
loves it yeah he's a lad oh good stuff
okay this one's also from must be
another inside joke all of these
um why does everyone call you a joke
is that a hollow hollow or something nah
yopu oh
yeah that's just I don't know me and
your pool just use the few inside jokes
I used to call him a joke oh he used to
call me a joke I'll call him four eyes
just a bit of bantery I missed that guy
yeah
okay next one who was the best Mafia at
the Stags and were you Mafia ah
bro do you not got any Michael Stewart
he's down in Christchurch he's a he's a
he
um yeah so he played with me in South
and south of him and he was a qualified
lawyer
and he just used to eat it up it
at Mafia
just you know making us doubt our own
make us believe that you know we're not
even Mafia about in a way with words
that would you know maybe I am Mafia
so yeah that Michael's short he's one of
the all-time Mafia great oh it's true
lawyers yeah I could imagine them being
good at that okay next one favorite
story from The Barbarians we didn't even
get to touch on your barbarians um times
but oh mate that would have been good
times you're playing with like what
Reggie bradshields yeah a few other Lads
so yeah
yeah Milani was there now we had a cool
crew
but just just spending that time with
Brad was special ed because I was his
roomie the whole time oh yeah
so you know
coming from you know at the canes or he
was you know he had to be the
he had to be the
you know enforcer of rules and kind of
hold the boys all accountable you know
touring with bread as a out of that
environment as a as a barbarian I was
just I just love seeing that side over
me
a different group he took me under his
wing that toy I just [__] he just
plus 100 respect of that already just a
such a good man and he just looked after
me and yeah yeah but bro we had some
funny funny times of prayer because
yeah we just you know it's a lot of
drinking on The Barbarians tour and we
just had some good nights and I remember
one of the last nights we've
we just we missed the bus and you know
we're just
us to the last
last minute standing like just I don't
know silly things but bro looking back
now in fact that was funny yeah yeah and
did you you play against South Africa
was that yeah yeah we
it was crazy because well we like did no
training or anything and then we we went
and Drew with the spring box crazy yeah
it does it was just everyone just
flipped flicked the switch and we were
just just balling that game hey you
obviously were pretty good at that like
being able to just flick that switch so
you're probably like the perfect Barb
ass man right used to a toxic Tuesday
and being able to flick a switch no
training
no it was it kind of just made you like
realize you know Rugby's
that's that's you don't have to
you know train like a madman during the
week and
you know you could kind of
get away with
you know being a bit more relaxed about
things and you know when you're relaxed
you you sometimes tend to play better
which is true for a lot of people so
barbarians was that was a fun tour we
yeah we ended up
we ended up beating Fiji
we beat Czech Republic and we drew off
Spring boxing or just all around you
know we had fun yeah it's there's
something in there it's crazy how well
The Barbers go against International
Teams yeah just when you're having fun
dancing like and a good in a good
headspace eh it just brings that sort of
enjoyment back which is huge
right crazy okay next one two left yeah
what's the biggest lesson he has learned
what he wish he knew at the start of his
career
yeah I don't actually know just
just not doubting your own ability
and
you know that's only one coach's opinion
a lot of players you know once they they
don't make a few teams or
or you know they're not they're not
progressing in their career they they
start to believe that and
even I started to believe that
so you know just believing in yourself
and backing yourself and
yeah
and you know if you keep stay consistent
and just keep keep training yeah
keep knocking on that door it's gonna
bust down eventually so you know that's
me just you know self-belief is huge and
just don't lose it mate I love that and
that that's that's like very much like
this question I always ask this question
at the end of every episode best piece
of advice for a wood LED listener you
may have given a sneak peek already or
you might even have something new for us
ah
advice for what allowed listener um
well you know what my advice is is just
bro don't take your don't take your body
for granted don't take your Able Body
for granted
because you know
you only get one body so so look after
it and
you know if you if you're looking for a
reason like me I've lost I've lost my
Able Body and
and I'll kill to get it get my body back
but you know it's impossible so
or if you have an Able Body
look after it
because [__] I'll take it [__] yeah mate
that is definitely the most powerful the
Goosebumps hit me all down my spine
again but get trading to me
[Laughter]
how many people take their body for
Grant today it's yeah it's crazy when
you when you've got these things
um it's very easy to just you know think
it's it's yours and you do take it for
granted but like you say life
um your body all these things can be
taken off yet in a moment so mate you're
speaking you're speaking true facts here
and from
a person who's who's been through it all
but mate what a podcast
um I now know why I was so excited to
get you on that was one of the most
incredible stories I've heard
um so cool to hear it from your side of
things and I'm so proud of you for what
you've done
um not not just post your injury but
leading up to it mate your credible
career and then post post injury what
you've done is just um
been so amazing and so awesome to see
and seeing seeing you do so well
um looking strong looking healthy
looking a good head space and yeah and
being willing to come on and and share
your story which I'm sure so many people
get a lot out of
um and yeah looking forward to following
you in the future keeping in touch and
hopefully seeing you at the Paralympics
during The discus 20 meters further than
everyone else
it's not a quadriplegic give of it uh
thanks for having me Jimmy yeah um no
first podcast I've ever done so I
scale also a few I love that I
appreciate it appreciate you choosing me
man because um like I said it's such a
cool story you've been through it and uh
yeah it's awesome seeing where you are
now so appreciate you bro bro can I get
some water land merch or what
yeah 100 next order we are on you are
the ultimate lead so I need it I need a
mix uh Paralympics man you'll be running
with a whirl
all right first what a LED athlete
I appreciate it very helpful
[Music]